you know when i felt the most shameful i
was working at fat
cells and what bob used to do
and then i was in the kitchen and i
remember i had to do the walk of shame
because like my manager's like i think
your brother's here and i had my apron
on
and i just remember like having to walk
out there
but man that was a hard job i had a bag
meat i was washing dishes
i almost lost my fingernails when i was
making a milkshake because i was the
milkshake they called me the milk the
bruce lee of milkshake yeah yeah
kind of racist but yeah but it was
racist yeah okay and i remember
like you know how like the orders
like that's a great one you're like
that's hilariously
the orders kept piling up like the
ticket yeah so i was like panicking
because i had to do like the mozzarella
cheese stick
then i had to wash the dishes i was like
multitasking in there
and then i remember i was i was like
panicking and then
there's like these big cartons of um ice
you know
and they sometimes they get stuck at the
bottom and then you know when the ice
cream gets low you have to kind of dig
your
arm in your whole body so you know how
like like on the outside of the liner
was this
uh metal silver lining and so i
i like i did i i like try to
it got caught yeah my fingernail and
then i got lodged
in the
so i was just screaming for uh i think
my boss's name was zayn i'm like
you know i was like yelling first thing
but we know i mean
those are hard jobs our jobs man so um
what's the worst out of all of those
jobs which one did you
hate the most oh no go ahead sarah
well there's a i have a long i got a lot
of those jobs
yeah most of them i mean i worked at the
the kentucky state fair
that was a bad one i mean it's fun but
you're i was worked at the greater tater
hut so it was like
in the middle of summer and in august
in kentucky it's very humid and like and
it was just two big bats of grease and
they never change out the v's
the grease for the whole fair that's
gross so yeah and at the time i was
younger and prone to acne
like you know and like doing these
grease and there's like a
line of 200 people out there who want
like a twirled potato with extra cheap
you know i mean you're like
[ __ ] you you know breaking on whiteheads
i've
one blackhead growing as i was you know
horrible and like
they're demanding like four ladles of
cheese and i have a manager who's like
just give him one light let's see it you
know and you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know it's a dilemma so
it's stuff like that and i was terrible
at customer service and food because
eventually i would just give it away i
was like just take it
just take the food i don't want to just
just take it
don't tell anybody like are you sure
i'll pay i was like nah just take it
i must have been hard working it was
horrible
like the weather i did that for years oh
god anytime you're working in a kitchen
or with grease it's rough
horrible you know sushi dance for me
well
that's the one where it was at the stab
well i almost found a fight with the
sushi chef
oh my god and then i almost got in a
fight with the uh manager too
steve that's the way they talked to me
was you know i would
not square up with a sushi chef though
because they're just so good with knives
and they have they
you know they're all about accuracy i
know but the way
uh he talked to me was a bit
condescending and
really disrespectful you know my friend
sam got stabbed by the sushi chef
i didn't care i blacked out anyway oh
sam sam oh he got stabbed he got
stabbed yeah i was already in the red
zone with him
um but then they kind of kept it on the
down low and they were like here's some
money just don't like
report to the police yeah that's assault
and uh
yeah he could have got jail time for
that yeah
so uh the way he talked to me
was he would be like yeah
you go go go you know he would speak
korean yeah he would speak korean
yeah you go you go go and i'd be like
hey man like you can't talk to me like
that we're in america now dude like
like this is america you know we're not
in korea you know what i mean yeah you
can't talk
you know and then i remember so that
happened and then
that's hard work because like especially
if it's like an eight top
yeah and you're not even you're not even
a waiter or waitress you're a barback
slash buster yeah so you're not even
getting the real
true tips you're getting the tips from
the waiters and waitresses
it's a trickle still out of whack 08 of
everybody's yeah and then even the woman
manager she was korean too but i
remember like she
got another dish all right thank you so
much what is it say it out loud jules
this is switch on do you eat pork
yeah i eat everything okay